the Roman Catholic Church faces its
biggest crisis in the United States
since the Boston sex abuse scandal 13
states and the District of Columbia are
now investigating whether abuse was
concealed by church leaders including
bishops the highest-ranking clergy in a
Catholic Diocese one place under
scrutiny is Buffalo New York 60 minutes
has learned the FBI is interviewing
church insiders there Buffalo Bishop
Richard Malone is accused of allowing
priests accused of sexual abuse to stay
on the job
deacon Paul Snyder was the first member
of the local clergy to call for the
bishop to step down he spoke with Bill
Whitaker for this Sunday's 60 minutes
bishop Malone has called this crisis you
call it a scandal what's the difference
a crisis is we look at our home and it's
burning to the ground a scandal is while
it's burning to the ground you know how
to put the fire up but you don't tell me
you also know how the fire was caused
but you don't tell me so you pretend to
grieve with me about the fire but the
problem is you caused it Schneider
showed us some of the 400 notes and
emails he has received since calling for
the bishop to resign like they want to
be part of a solution but they think
this bishop is preventing that from
occurring many are from victims this
month
Snyder sent letters and documents to
prominent bishops demanding an
investigation why do you have faith that
the bishops are going to handle this
well I don't have faith right now that
any particular bishops have the courage
to do the right thing I mean we all
praise our martyrs on Sunday then we
praise and we sing but boy it sure as
hell is hard being a saint
what is your ass on the line and I want
these Cardinals and these bishops to
start putting their ass on the line and
start protecting their people bishop
malone declined 60 minutes his request
for an interview he did speak to Buffalo
CBS affiliate WI VB in an interview that
aired last night saying in part I have
apologized for mistakes I made in how we
handled allegations of a cleric getting
involved in Muskaan
with an adult I have never ever
knowingly and intentionally left a
priest in ministry who I knew had abused
a child or moved him from one assignment
to another or let him stay in ministry
ever the Whitacre now joins us at the
table bill good morning good morning so
what do you make of that statement bill
well we do know that this year once the
allegations started to percolate in
Buffalo the bishop has taken some
actions but we also know from the
documents and from our reporting that
for years there were priests who had
credible accusations of sexual
harassment and in one case statutory
rape and little or nothing was done and
was only once this started to come to
light that the church in Buffalo started
to take some action well one of the
whistleblowers you talked to was the
bishops executive assistant you don't
get much closer to a person than their
executive assistant though who normally
knows everything about what's going on
what can you tell us about her and why
did she decide to speak up now she told
us that she felt compelled to speak
compelled by her faith and by her
religion to speak up she went into the
job it was her dream job she was working
for the bishop and she's a very very
faithful person and she started to see
things that just didn't seem right did
she say something to him about it she
did she was getting phone calls from
victims she was answering the phone and
she would just hear repeatedly of these
stories of people who had been abused by
priests and she tried to get the bishop
to address this and she also she always
felt as though she were getting the
brush-off you know not now not now and
this went on for a while and she felt
the only way she could handle this was
to start to leak this information that
she had you could sense the anger from
the deacon what finally motivated him to
call for the resignation of Bishop
Malone
first of all the information he didn't
know who the whistleblower was but this
information is being revealed on
television in Buffalo one of the priests
in the documents was the priest in his
parish and the documents and that
evidence about that priest just was it
was the last straw for him so he's
taking me within the Catholic Church the
extraordinary step of calling for the
bishop to resign it's been 16 years
since the church scandal in Boston the
cuts started all of this the movie
spotlight if everybody remembers that
what do you think makes this different
well in terms of what we've learned
about Buffalo what makes this one
different is that we've got this
whistleblower inside who is revealing
this information and the information
it's it's hundreds and hundreds of pages
of memos emails personnel files that
show that the church knew that these
activities were going on and took steps
not to address it but to in her words
cover it up Wow I'll be watching oh yeah
they're always incredible reporting I
know by you and the producers it's a few
minutes great job you can see Bill's
entire report on 60 minutes this Sunday
right here on CBS